what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
oh my god Rob core Doomsday Clock oh my
god this story is so good is this issue
this first issue is everything I hoped
it would be
is it incredible start to an incredible
story I can I get mad I can
guaran-damn-tee that all right so a
little bit of history here
the original Watchmen a comic in a lot
of ways played out like the film I mean
there were a lot of aspects of the film
that were pretty much the same there
were two main differences between the
film and really just one main difference
between the film and the comics the
biggest difference was that instead of
Ozymandias that any bombs in these
different cities across the world
instead what he did is he unleashed this
giant monster on the city of New York
but the whole idea remains the same the
world for the most part was on the brink
of chaos that nuclear war was going to
engulf everything it was like if the
cold war between the United States and
Russia never ended and so because of
that with the original Watchmen taking
place in 1985 the idea of Ozymandias was
if people cannot unite on their own did
what they need is they need a common
enemy a common goal they need a singular
banner to unite under and so creating
this this massive catastrophe in the
city of New York this massive event that
cost somewhere near the the lives of
three million people ultimately united
society in a way that people never
really thought before and so what we
find out in this story is that where the
end of the watchman saw this unification
of humanity the sort of you know 1:1
pact one world kind of thing ultimately
by 1992 where the story kicks off it had
all gone to pot and the reason for that
was because in the original Watchmen
comic war Shack was basically going
through and he was notating everything
that had happened that was the basis of
Rorschach's Journal it was documenting
this whole event that was unfolding so
by the time the story came to an end and
you found out that Adrian Veidt this guy
who was formerly a superhero who had
turned you know philanthropist and
businessman where he was the one that
was originally behind it all this was
basically documented of were shacks
Journal so at the end of the story when
were shacks Journal was sent to the
press and the press began running this
article of the fact that it was all just
a giant ruse that it was what people now
refer to as the great lie the society
felt deeper into chaos than it was
before because now they felt like
they've been tricked and they felt like
3 million people had been sacrificed as
opposed to you know people finding a
hope on their own now this is cool
geoff johns is not really a writer to
focus on like the dark side of human
but the cool thing about this is that it
almost seems to hit it home at the
nature of people to take kind of a
cynical approach here and I'm not really
cynical by nature but the humanity was
at a fork in the road they were giving
us information that said hey look it was
basically a ruse it was this guy Adrian
Veidt the world's smartest man who had
engineered the deaths of 3 million
people to unite all of you under a
single banner because you were acting
like children and you couldn't do it on
your own and when Humanity was given the
choice of will do we continue this trend
and do we say yeah I mean maybe he was
right maybe we did need to see your
cause and those 3 million people's
sacrifice can be honored by creating a
better world or we can just descend back
in the chaos again and just totally ruin
any sacrifice they made humanity chose
to descend back into chaos again and so
it's very much a kind of Grant Morrison
desk Alan Moore method of storytelling
where it's like where they they take
these kind of concepts and they
basically said all the worst things that
happen in the world happened because of
people because people do them maybe a
lot easier if we could point our finger
at a super villain but to quote you know
V for Vendetta if people are looking for
the guilty party they need only look
into a mirror and that's the whole point
of this that's the whole basis behind
this is to say humans are responsible
for all the terrible things that happen
and so one thing I want you guys to also
notice too is that we're getting this
sort of monologue this almost like a
diary entry in terms of how all this is
happening which is interesting because
we're shaq died at the end of the first
watchman and so it's kind of cool
because the question becomes well who is
it that's narrating this who it is who
is it this going through and making this
whole discussion and talking about these
things now the other half of this is
that we end up finding out that after
the events of you know really like this
this revelation from Adrian Veidt so on
and so forth that political parties in
the United States began using it as a
means to try to consolidate you know
power under one another and that's kind
of the cool thing because in a lot of
ways this almost heaters on the basis
behind the the TV show Jericho oh how
many of you guys ever saw Jericho but
Jericho was a great show it was
basically this show that took place from
the perspective of the people who lived
in a town called Jericho and there's
this nuclear explosion in Colorado
Springs I think it was where NORAD is
based but people were just kind of
freaking out they were kind of panicking
but what you end up finding out is that
that was not the only nuclear detonation
instead some crazy faction got a hold of
nuclear weapons and detonated nuclear
bombs in 26 major US cities basically
bringing America to its knees and then
after that you had the eastern United
States
which is what was left of the federal
government and then everything west of
the Mississippi or the Rocky Mountains I
came from Burt which was the allied
States of America so you effectively had
the works being laid for a second civil
war within the United States and all
that hindered on the last remaining
nuclear bomb and it was just a great
race to try to get it this is very much
the same way people consolidating power
is designed to illustrate absolute chaos
and complete and total pandemonium not
only that because of the fact that this
is all predicated on the great lie it
means not only is the United States
descending into madness it's also other
countries to all these different news
agencies are reporting about how Russia
is invading other territories expanding
its empire different things like that
and that's why it's kind of crazy
because we don't know which of these is
true and when I say which of these we'll
find out here in a second but we into
finding out from this whole you know a
bit of a monologue is that the news
network started publishing it the news
networks started talking about it then
the government started systematically
shutting them down the government just
has a sweeping amount of power more so
than it had before the president's kind
of out of the picture nobody really
cares about what it is that he's doing
they're trying to figure out what it is
is going on but Adrian Veidt is the
world's most wanted man the world's on
the hunt for Adrian Veidt as the what we
end up doing is we actually end up
having a member of the press who's
actually inciting rebellion among the
people rise up against your government
and they're immediately quashed there
immediately silence and the whole idea
is that in turn we basically get the
national news network this giant
propaganda piece and that shows you how
far things have fallen in the span of
seven years from the end of the first
Watchmen story until this one starts
humanity experience this golden era of
peace and then humanity brought this
golden era of peace to an end and now we
basically have this propaganda machine
cranking out information Russia's
invaded Poland we have to respond with
nuclear weapons and so what we end up
doing is that in the middle of all this
panic in the middle of all this chaos
they basically pick up in a prison where
you know a guy's basically trying to
orchestrate a prison break by attacking
a guard and when he goes to knock this
guy out we end up having somebody pick
up the keys and this person is Rorschach
what how did horshack live where were
shot come from now here's a funny thing
so we were at New York Comic Con and we
got the ashcan for this whole thing and
froze you guys you don't know the ash
cans basically like hey here's just kind
of a preview rough draft kind of a thing
on what the story's going to be you know
what the story's gonna look like and it
was super cool because like myself
income
storia we were sitting in the panel with
like geoff johns and maybe like five or
six hundred other people and geoff johns
is like hey so do you guys want to see
like the preview for like four for
tuesday o'clock and we're like yeah man
like we really want to see that and so
he so he starts running over like
showing the previa neveri thing and he
got to this point dude the top plumb
came off that place you guys should have
seen it it was bananas people were
freaking out over the fact that
Rorschach came back we basically picked
up with were Shaq as he makes his way
through and this is very Rorschach esque
in terms of how this thing unfolds he
went to a diner you know on you know to
get some breakfast and the woman that
normally serves this pancake syrup you
know her boyfriend took her you know out
back and then she came back with bruises
and a busted lip were shocked found the
guy stabbed a fork through his tongue
broke his hands I mean it was it was
amazing and you know it's just it's
awesome to see this this this cool
monologue unfold but were shocked is
basically talking about how the u.s.
gave Russia a four-hour ultimatum if
Russia does not back off from invading
Poland in four hours then the United
States is going to use nuclear weapons
now the whole idea grabbing that idea of
like the national news network and the
propaganda machine and rolling it over
into what we're shocked is basically
telling us this is basically nonsense is
this scenario where the United States
government is feeding the American
people false information under the
auspices of creating a reason for why it
is that they want to either attack
Russia or disable Russia or something
along those lines now the indication
here is that with Adrian Veidt having
this global sharing information for the
most part that Russia knows all the
strategic points of the United States
and how to basically [ __ ] the US
using nuclear weapons and so the goal of
the u.s. is to create a common threat to
say see Russia's the bad guy stop
protesting us we need to worry about
Russia everybody focus on Russia and
then launch nuclear weapons in Russia
what we end up finding out is that where
these nuclear weapons are being prepared
to launch you know we're just they're
just waiting on the three-and-a-half
hour mark to hit we end up having
Rorschach locate someone by the name of
marionette now there is a reason for why
these characters are here and we'll talk
about that in a second but one thing I
hope you also notice about how Rorschach
talks is that it's very much in broken
English when horshack spoke in The
Watchmen comics for the most part it was
kind of broken to a degree but it was
still like traditional English you know
regular English the way that we normally
speak it does feed him to the idea that
if this is Rorschach who's returned for
the dead then things just
quite right from him you know right with
his character it was kind of cool in
terms of how this unfolds but but
regards to the character of marionette
were shocked popping up basically says
hey look I'm gonna hire you for a job
and the payment for this job is a
location of where your child is and this
is cool because marionette freaks out it
immediately tries to attack horshack now
from there her her idea is well then we
have to find my husband we have to find
mine and this is cool because once they
locate mine is in the middle of this
massive Prison Break regards are being
beaten up in different things like that
and we end up finding out that mime is
putting on somewhat of a show in the
sense that we're a couple of prisoners
consider him to be sort of nonsense the
fact that he never talks you know when
were shocked at marionette show up
marionette makes the case well this is
just part of my show just wait and watch
and mine
basically responds by just killing all
these prisoners but the reason why I say
these are characters but John's put in
here intentionally was because during
New York comic-con John's had basically
said these are versions of Punch and
Julie now punch and Julie are old
Charlton comic characters and they made
their appearance back in Captain Atom
number 85 in 1967 now of course we
talked about Charlton comics before one
of a myriad of coming book publishers
really from like the 1940s going into
the 1960s the problem was by the time
the 1970s and 80s came around
Charlton just wasn't able to stay afloat
anymore and so DC had basically
purchased up a lot of the characters
that they had and then wrote those
characters into DC itself which is where
we got Blue Beetle different things like
that but punch it Julie were basically
just these nonsensical characters they
were characters where they basically
found some alien technology they ran a
puppet show called Punch and Judy and
the whole thing was that when they
became criminals they started calling
themselves Punch and Julie and that was
really it most recently in DC rebirth
they were part of I am Bane where Batman
broke into a Santa Prisca
where he was forming a Suicide Squad of
his own of sorts in order to invade
Bane's prison that was really the basis
behind that you know for the purpose of
taking psycho-pirate bring you back to
Gotham in order to cure Gotham girl
again I have that in the Batman playlist
you guys are welcome to check out that's
the actual punch in Julie over there
these characters mime and marionette are
based on those characters grabbing a
vehicle and taking off what they end up
doing is of course were shocked he's
making allusions to is to his partner
you know now the indication here is
because the direction they go in their
partner is actually Night Out and that's
cool here because they go to like you
know that the owl ship and they're in
the base of the old 9-hour they have the
night owl suit and everything there but
what
finding out is his partner is not
neidell his partner is Ozymandias and i
was just like what no way it was crazy
because Ozymandias has been hiding
underground this entire time he's been
just underground and he basically
grabbed were shocked but we also find
out is this is not the Rorschach that we
know it's not the were shocked that
we're familiar with somebody took over
his name somebody took the title of were
shocked after the original Rorschach
died who that person is we don't know
but the cool thing about this is that
Ozymandias really kind of hits on the
mistake that he made what he says is I
do not have the means to fix the world
we don't even know if the world can be
fetched but if the world can be fixed if
it can be restored back to the place
that is supposed to be there's only one
person who can do it and that person is
dr. Manhattan we have to find dr.
Manhattan at this point we cut away from
the whole Watchmen from from everything
with the Watchmen and we pick up with
Superman what this does is it seems to
pick up with like a flashback or a dream
of sorts and he's actually talking to
Martha Kent talking to Jonathan Cain
about a problem that he's going to that
kind of a thing but notice the way this
is done this is throwback to Superman's
secret origin those you guys don't know
geoff johns wrote a few secret origins
stories and for the most part secret
origins are just a line of publications
that DC has they're basically just more
condensed down versions of the origins
as they appear and they usually point
like two or three and any one particular
publication but the whole idea was that
with geoff johns secret origin of
Superman it was like a six or seven
issues story but detailed this brand new
origin for the character of Superman and
that's what's been used really as part
of DC rebirth in a lot of ways now
Superman reborn changed a lot of that
stuff but it also brought a lot of those
things back to so it kind of rolled in
this perfect origin for the new 52 flash
classic Superman melded into a singular
character but with regards to this
version of Superman we're kind of left
to assume that you know it's it's them
the one that we see now in DC we birth
but it's not and we'll find out why here
in a second but the cool thing is that
he's basically reflecting on this whole
they own this dance you know this dance
party of sorts that he's going to and
the funny thing is that back in in his
younger years
Superman really kind of had the hots for
Lana Lang she was the first person who
learned that he had powers basically and
she was the one that helped to train him
to use his powers to figure out how he
could fly to figure out how to control
his vision different things like
and so she was very much an intricate
part of him becoming a superhero as much
as John and Martha Kent were and
teaching him his moral compass but it's
kind of cool because back in these
younger days where he had feelings for
Lana in a lot of ways Pete Ross one of
the other friends at Clark Kent had was
the first one to ask out Longway the
problem with this is that is John and
Martha Kent are driving home they
basically end up in a car wreck and
that's where they die and Superman snaps
out of it now the reason why I say this
is not the Superman that we're familiar
with is because Superman's parents as
far as I'm aware never died in a car
crash Jonathan and Martha Kent have died
but like usually Jonathan died of a
heart attack and Martha Kent wasn't long
after that their passing has been done
in different ways but it's still kind of
a big moment because this seems to hit
at the idea this is not the Superman
we're familiar with this is a totally
isolated Superman if the events of you
know doomsday caught are taking place on
a earth somewhere then that means it's
got to be taking place on an earth in a
different universe
and it is taking place in a different
universe and the washer rolled into the
DC universe or DC multiverse now then it
stands to reason that universe may very
well have his own version of Superman
well the question has to be asked if
that version of Earth has its own
Superman where's he been all this time
and that's the crazy thing is because
again as far as I'm aware
Superman's parents never died in a car
crash now this may be a change and there
may be some progress of origin that I'm
missing over here and if there is I'm
sure a lot of you guys will correct me
down in the comments but it's huge this
is big because what this does is a deal
it basically hits at this idea Superman
has never had a nightmare before he's
never experienced a bad dream in his
life you know him having this nightmare
means one of two things it means either
it's organic or someone's messing with
Superman but it's kind of crazy because
the question becomes what happens next
which we'll have to find out in the next
comic that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later please
[Music]